so uh Jesus frigging intense episode
this is like the first one this is
mortal Bali and this is the first one
that actually felt like like
intimidating like the villain in this I
mean doesn't even say that much but just
they really established this presence
and and this great design which I was
asking they did show this guy before
right cuz I remember the design but I
don't remember where when there's doing
the Billy song um they briefly show
Billy kicking him I don't know
everything the Lich and that's when they
bear the name - the Lynch - yeah and
that's when she said when she was
talking about it when the snail is like
slowly doing his thing he's she's
talking about how it was Billy Hugh
knocked him into the amber okay and
everything that's Billy's gauntlets well
with the six fingers - I thought I was
gonna get that going and yeah I just
great design great name if I even
remember that from that just that little
bit from in there so this thing is kept
in I don't know what that the secret
room and the other secret room and he
gets out and did you see this nail this
episode uh you know I think I missed it
um you know he goes by so fast yeah but
yeah so this um so he gets this gauntlet
that's he's gonna go and defeat you know
defeat the Lynch here and then I skip
that Lynch
oh is it lit Schlick okay kitsch that's
even better I like it
but then the Ice King comes then just
break it out know where wants Finn and
Jake's blessing to marry bubblegum which
makes no sense the fairy King makes tons
of sense just that like they're her
father or something it's both of them
somehow and yeah sure enough he's
constantly coming in like you know I get
me your blessing and they go to church I
think we're where was that place that
they went to again this is just a subway
oh just the subway okay I like
when they go to the beach they still
have the stuff set up from the episode
where he's getting used to the water to
Geno's the hoop yeah I like or know the
rock yeah the doctor like they had a lot
of that stuff I was still set up and
they go to this place and they they
tried to feed him he loses the crown but
that's supposed to keep stop the guy
from hypnotizing him but then he has the
sweater of lacking someone a lot and I
think it's like especially violent like
he takes the sweater off and puts like
through his eye socket it pulls it back
and eventually like rips the eye sockets
out of it it's like if I was a sensor I
don't know what I would head out what I
would do with this episode because it's
like holy crap that's an intense violent
image but on the other hand it is a
skull I mean it's not like blood or skin
or oozing or anything like that what
skin you know what's our like a layer of
skin up until like his jaw his mouth and
it's just like flapping skin yeah and
then Ice King is so moved by how
touching it was he lets bubblegum goes
she falls into this pit and iris out and
apparently it's a two-parter right now
was this one like was this something
where next week they were gonna do it or
was it like you had to wait a whole
season or what no no it wasn't like
that's the thing like as far as you know
heat signature was a season finale which
is kind of silly considering this would
have made a great season finale but I
didn't actually watch it as it was
airing on TV so I can't actually comment
on that okay but I think it was just
like oh just a week I don't think it was
a full season cuz I guess part of season
two okay okay okay
and it reminded me a touch of the
tree-trunks
ending where she just blows up and then
it's like you know wow what happened um
but this way it seems like there's a
definite hey we're gonna find out next
time what happens like and I can explain
how they I can't explain how it sort of
has that feel maybe cuz make it if it
just cut that I wouldn't know but I
think because they sort of had the slow
awkward iris he's gone
so yeah I liked it because like I said
with the with the Lich it felt really
there's great presence a great voice
that's ron perlman
yeah yeah i mean just it doesn't say
much by me just really effective him
really creepy uh and just a lot of
moments holding on him and holding on
you know him controlling Finn and just
everything goes black it's like really
it's really menacing it is really
intimidating um I love the way you
shouts I'm not cold I have a sweater the
only thing I want your opinion on this
with the Ice King coming in I know it's
part of his character but there's maybe
it's just a me thing or Mazar people I
don't know but I always get really
really irritated when like something
important is trying to go on and here's
somebody with a petty problem constantly
interrupting and I know I know that's
the point it supposed to be annoying it
and that's the comedy of it but it
legitimately annoys me so I really did
kind of want to punch him a few times in
this episode um but is that just a me
thing or a lot of people are like no no
that's actually just funny well I mean
it's funny but at the same time it's
like up until this point in time and
Finn said it himself this is our first
you know end of the world type thing
bubblegum is saying you know the Lich
will kill everyone it's not some minor
little villain or something like that it
was it's not even like something
personal that Finn and Jake have to deal
with this is like a global thing and a
global whoo yes
and um globe ooh and the thing is is if
he notices it's going on finish getting
more and more frustrated with the Ice
King normally yeah he noticed he kind of
holds back he doesn't actually get sorry
he walks with Ameren doesn't get super
ticked off but there's the time where
they're running and he just picks up the
rock and Huck's an atom and the excuse
like whoa you know like what's going on
here you're really upset but the Ice
King is kind of a bumbling idiot who's
in his own little world but doesn't know
the severity of what's going on
yeah it's like you feel the frustration
of finding this one you really like you
dude but also no one took the time to
tell Ice King what's going on hmm
because no one's saying we have
something really important to do it's
the end of the world or constantly you
probably be like you know oh you're just
lying to me or trying to get rid of me
and not give me your blessing I don't
know if that's how are you really tired
does he have a lisp I know there's
nothing I just like giving him that
because I think Edwin has a bit of a
lisp and I go and Edwin whenever I do
that voice I don't know why but ya know
it's it's frustrating
yeah it's it's frustrating but it's I
know it's good comedy I know it's funny
it's just I really wanted to punch him
it's what was it because you were so
drawn into the episode and what was
going on with the Lich and he was
consistently stopping Finn sure that you
were kind of like feeling that whole
thing of oh my god if you just stop we
could you know Finn could defeat the
Lich yeah maybe that's it maybe I feel
like you're stopping the story from
moving further and maybe it's also that
I know where this is gonna go it's it's
like all those little things combined
together that just get me really
frustrated watching it even for
something that's just 11 minutes but the
other thing I really really like the I
like how expressive the eye oh yeah it
is I mean that's it as someone who is an
illustrator drawing an expression with
one eye is very tricky because when you
have two eyes people want to look angry
you know you have the eye brows go down
or worry the mm can go up up it's it's
too wise here to do it with with one eye
that's really tricky and they really
have that thing as well oh but it's like
you know hey it's me and the waiter
looks up and it looks like they really
make that thing act well yeah I was
really impressed with that
so ya know a good episode very dark very
intimidating and I'm curious to know
where the next one goes anything else
two of my favorites was when the Ice
King first shows up and they shut the
door on I mean he's like no no not the
lash I just put the tiny little latch
down I use the credit card to Iran yeah
he shows up and you see the credit card
as Princess Bubblegum
it's grabbing the part of one of the ice
cream people's heads and just eating it
and then the card I just love the fact
that this world has credit cards like
there's banks I know there's electronic
payments I don't think it's a credit
card I think it's one of his wizard club
memberships oh okay what am i which that
man I see later on but one of the other
parts that I'm God what was it that I
like to know I can't remember it started
talking about banks and Sephora yeah
you're thinking about the financial
situation of yeah yeah I will see this
one maybe while you're thinking about is
that my brother has a book or hurts my
dad I came here but it's a it's like an
atlas of fictional worlds oh yeah which
is yeah I was always like is this a good
idea or a dumb idea but actually it's a
it's pretty neat you know I'll have like
middle-earth in there and RDI you know
and stuff and I love to see ooh yeah I
love to see this actually maps out
somehow if there is like an actual map
of it you know or do they make it all up
you know or it has someone actually gone
to see if they can actually track where
everything is the more and more you give
from the show or it maybe they release
something I don't know a be interested
I'd be kind of cool to have actually I'd
like to actually have a map of you on
the wall yeah because I'm shocked
especially the more and more like in the
episode where they were filming stuff
that go around just sort of filling
characters doing whatever they do and
stuff it's a world surprisingly you kind
of want to be in ya know what's going on
over there or what's in this place what
do adventures are they see you actually
do kind of want to live in this place
you know it's at first you sort of thing
like oh it's just whatever Mario Zelda
ish looking you know just service that
tire that but it actually has sort of
developed its own environment oh yeah
which is pretty cool and they're very
detailed too even though they're just
line drawings it's still there's a lot
going on those backgrounds and I think
it it definitely shows that really does
help create the environment very well so
remember here yes actually with the Lich
himself like I think that is like an
extremely badass design it like I really
of the Lich but one of my favorite parts
I don't know if you caught it is when
Finn takes up the sweater and I love the
shot of here's the Lich who's just huge
and Finn's running up the stairs and
it's like I love that shot to animation
or camera or whatever work it's like
Lich is getting bigger as spin is going
up and nae jumps off and everything that
was very nicely animated but was what
was also disturbing is he puts you know
the the sweater through his eyesight
because he starts yanking what's the
Lich doing I was he laughing yeah
continue everything is that that this
guy is literally about to get his head
ripped off and he's doing nothing but
laughing which just adds more to the
weirdness and creepy vibe of the Lich
himself does he come back it's too good
a design a voice a character a present
that's I hope he comes back cuz that's
it's a pretty badass villain no what
about Princess Bubblegum aren't you
worried about people's yeah okay late
boy this way that they're not a they're
not gonna kill her off because she's way
too popular be it looks like it's a to
be continued so the pride just say was
gonna happen there in the next one and
see it's the air that would have
exploded if they did that I mean if she
has to have a fan base you know like
everyone be ladylike so old this episode
is that's what I mean it's like so this
would be like the red wedding just every
but this will be the pink wedding
everybody would know what's coming you
know and they would ruin it for everyone
else just be like you know that episode
where she finally gets axed or something
so so she come out now she comes out
mutated and weird now than the B
cosplays of that all over the place no I
think she's fine okay so the red wedding
really a game of Thrones reference
compared to defense your time
Game of Thrones has nothing at Adventure
Time and yes I'll get lashings for that
but I don't care I stand by it
check please